so I can use that length if I can come
back to the original triangle here right
this is four thirds a like so
and what that allows me to do is I can
actually say hey hold on a second this
four thirds a and this six over here
they can combine so you remember I've
got this length on this side and this
length over here they can combine to be
this whole length but on the bottom side
of the rectangle do you see that so if I
just highlight that a little bit for you
this length here is the same as this
length up here so I can just do it by
addition right so this is six plus four
thirds a
okay now have a look at this this is
brilliant we are so close right if you
look closely I've got a right angle
triangle here in the corner it's the
same writing which I got there six plus
four thirds a is one of the shorter
lengths eight minus a is another shot of
length and it just gives you X now you
might be sorely tempted to say oh this
is great I can actually combine these
two together but you're going to find
that uh it's not enough right so let's
actually have a look at this um this
triangle here and I might just uh give
it a one more color just so that we can
that's not what I meant to do just so
that we can follow this in our working
so let's grab this one
like so and then let's make it uh let's
make it purple shall we
not just the outline I always do this
okay fantastic all right so what we're
going to do is in this right angle
triangle I can say that eight take away
a squared there's one shorter side and
six plus four thirds a square there's
the other shorter side is equal to x
squared so that's that's really great
I've got now a relationship between the
A's and the x's and that's going to help
me solve this right
I can say well let's just simplify this
out I guess I'll expand gives me 64.
take away 16 a plus a squared and then
I'm also going to have 36 all right just
be careful here these two are going to
be multiplied together and then doubled
so the six times four over three is
going to be eight because six divided by
three is just two and then I double so
that gives me 16 a and then finally I've
got this term over here being squared so
that gives me careful with it 16 over 9
a squared that's all equal to x squared
you can see here I've got a bunch of
like terms here that I can just sort of
collect together and if I make x squared
the subject looking closely you've got
64 and 36 which gives you a hundred
the this is really nice
um I've got uh take away 16a and a plus
16a so they just eliminate each other
and then finally if you combine your a
squared terms hopefully you can see this
is going to be 25 over 9 a squared
so this is nice but like I said before
it's not enough right x squared is in
terms of a but what is a there's got to
be something else that I can do with a
some other relationship in this diagram
that can help me solve what a itself is
and then I'll use that to substitute
into let's I know we're going to
substitute back into this equation so
let's just give it a name it's called x
squared okay or one rather equation one
now let me pause this is my favorite
part of this problem right because so
far we've done similar triangles we've
done Pythagoras we've done a lot of
reasoning and it seems like we're so
close but a seems to be eluding us right
a um it's we don't know where it was
positioned because we know this is the
midpoint but we don't know what kind of
ratio it produces here right
what is the final piece of the puzzle I
wonder if it is clicking for you again
this is just like the start of the
question this is an appropriate point to
pause and say what what else can I see
here that will help me solve um or
evaluate a solve the question as a whole
um I've hopefully given you enough
warning before the spoilers come the the
final piece of the puzzle here right is
think back to how this question was
created I just love this it's delightful
right this question was not just created
by drawing like random lines and random
triangles and rectangles it was created
by taking a piece of paper
and folding it and remember we've
already used that relationship once
before we saw that when you start with
this right angle over here when you fold
it up it's still a right angle um over
here it's just facing in a different
direction right this is not the only
relationship that's been preserved when
you folded this piece of paper not only
is there a right angle here and a right
angle here look closely
did you notice
that this length over here which I have
marked in as 8 minus a where does it go
when you complete the fold and the
answer is and you'll see this if you
actually do the um the folding yourself
it becomes this hypotenuse uh over here
of the blue triangle in the top left
hand corner right can you see that
literally this this length here it sort
of rotates around and and swings up so
that it can bring this corner into the
right spot right so these two lengths
are equal but I have uh the the same
length stated in two different ways you
can see it right here right a take away
a looking at it from the side of that
rectangle and then Ace the square root
of a squared plus 36 using Pythagoras
Theorem so therefore I can equate these
this is delightful right so I'm doing
this in blue so let's use that I can say
eight take away a equals the square root
of a squared plus 36 what is our
reasoning and I think I'm going to say
by folding which is just delightful it's
not Pythagoras's Theorem it's that I
folded these things so there's
congruence going on between these links
so now what do I got here if I Square
this out I'm going to get a quadratic
in a but that quadratic in a the um the
A's are going to cancel out which we've
seen before it's going to give me a
linear equation in a and I can solve
that so let's go ahead and do this I'm
going to square both sides and that's
going to give me on the left hand side
64.
take away 16 a plus a squared on the
right hand side it's just going to get
rid of that radical that square root
side a squared plus 36 like I alluded to
before these a squareds are just going
to cancel
and so what do I get here I'm going to
get 16 a equals uh 64 take away 36 is 28
so a is 28 on 16. you can see that there
is a common factor of 4 on the numerator
and the denominator so I get 7 over 4
and I'm pretty much there right all I
need to do is to take this value of a
and substitute it back into that
equation one here so let's just write
that right substituting
a
into one what do I get well
I'm gonna get uh let's see here you can
see I've got the x squared on the left
hand side it's a hundred plus 25 on 9
times here comes a squared so it's 49 on
16 and hilariously there are no common
factors at all there because all of
these are squares and they're squares of
prime numbers right so you've got 5
squared here 3 squared here well that's
4 squared it's a bit cheeky but that's
fine it still doesn't cancel with
anything else and that's 7 squared so uh
what am I going to get here well
is going to be a hundred plus I've
actually already calculated this just to
make it a bit easier for us 1 225 on
144 up the top there that's going to
give you 15 625 on 144 and delightfully
you probably spotted the denominator
there is a square number so when you
take the square root you're just going
to get over 12 but you might not have
known that 15 625 is also a square
number it's a hundred and twenty five so
of course you could write that as a
misnumeral if you like but I'm just
going to leave that there because it's
exact
so in conclusion having a look at all
these different problems um and just
let's just go right back to that first
page right which shows all the problems
all together there we go all right
um it's delightful to me that it is the
same bit of mathematics underneath each
of them Pythagoras Theorem can be
applied in semi different contexts and
so you know mathematics is not just
about learning a formula and then saying
great I can rinse and repeat this over
and over again it's about like I've said
this many times mathematics is a lens
for looking at the world and seeing it
more clearly and if you can see a
mathematical reality like a right angle
triangle in places where maybe it's a
little bit obscure you can just use that
mathematical knowledge and understanding
to unpack and investigate and perhaps
solve the problem if you have eyes to
see it and that I think is one of the
the wonderful powers of mathematics